of markets and money
in the interview
nobel economics prize winner alvin roth
professor ross you are karate enthusiast
a high school dropout
a nobel laureate of economics
life-changing experiences seem to be
quite normal for you does it affect your
work
i think everyone has life-changing
experiences that's what life is about
surely it affects my work
but
but i didn't really drop out of high
school i went on and had further
education so i am not
a self-educated man i went to college i
went to graduate school i have a pretty
ordinary education why did you opt for
economics
well i didn't study economics i was
educated as an engineer
and i studied operations research
and operations research when i studied
it was mostly about the kind of
operations that went on in a factory in
a business so one decision maker trying
to organize all his operations but i was
interested in how people interact with
each other and how to coordinate
activity and that led me naturally to
economics how much does economics have
to do with actual with reality i mean is
it just theory or does it also have to
do with reality oh economics has very
much to do with reality uh
you know markets are ancient human
artifacts we've been making markets
probably as long as we've been making
languages which are also human artifacts
and and often we
we think of them as things that we
we can't change that we just have to
accept but market design the kind of
economics that that i've worked on and
many of my colleagues have
is about fixing markets when they're
broken making them work better and
creating markets where they're needed
what kind of markets are broken what do
you mean by that well
the most unusual market that i've worked
on in the united states is what we now
call kidney exchange
in the united states as in most of the
world it's against the law to buy and
sell organs for transplantation but
there's a great need for transplantation
and the available
supply of organs doesn't meet it but for
kidneys
it's
one of the sources of organs is live
donation uh you have two kidneys and if
you're as healthy as i hope you are then
you could give a kidney to someone you
love and save their life but sometimes
you can't give
a kidney to who you love even though
you're healthy enough to give someone a
kidney but your kidney doesn't match the
the person who needs it and i might be
in the same situation and i could give a
kidney to your patient and you could
give a kidney to mine and that's a
kidney exchange that's become a standard
form of transplantation now in the
united states
but it's against the law here in germany
so so germany hasn't
been able to participate in this
increased access to transplantation that
is found in holland and in england and
elsewhere in the eu so you created a
market for kidney well a market a market
is a bigger thing than just involving
money i study matching markets where
where
other things go on there are other
market clearing institutions than just
money so kidneys happen to be a market
in which we forbid the use of money to
decide who gets which kidney but but
nevertheless transactions exchanges can
increase the availability of transplants
if you want to give a kidney to someone
and i want to give a kidney to someone
but we can't but i can give a kidney to
your patient and you can give a kidney
to mine that creates two more
transplants that wouldn't have happened
otherwise through exchange
talking about markets can everything be
put down to markets
well so i use the word market more
broadly than than many people do
often in economics we think of commodity
markets things that that a price is
sufficient but but many markets aren't
like that job markets aren't like that
radio deutsche bella doesn't hire its
broadcasters and interviewers by by
lowering the wage until just enough
people want the job
presumably your job is a very desirable
one that lots of people would like to
have but deutsche bala chose you and and
they couldn't just choose you you had to
choose them you had other opportunities
so so
labor markets employment is not a market
that's said only by the price by the
wage but it has
lots of other features and once you
start thinking of markets that way
many of the ways that we coordinate and
cooperate and compete are markets but do
you see also markets
going wrong like for example financial
markets which seems to be very much
governed by greed the one has the
impression well markets again are human
artifacts and sometimes they work the
way we want and sometimes they don't and
then we should try to fix them so uh
it's certainly true that that markets
have rules that
change and can be changed and can be
regulated and all of those are things we
should always be thinking about
monitoring the markets and see if
they're doing the job that we want them
to do
are you sometimes worried about the
markets what markets are doing sure
that's what market designers do we we
worry about what markets are doing and
see if we can fix them whether they're
working as well as they should so for
instance i think a lot about labor
markets and whether employment
opportunities are being distributed the
way we would like them to be
you know when there's a
an economic crisis there's
one of the painful parts of economic
crisis is unemployment
and a lot of unemployment has to do just
with the
suppression of economic activity with
lack of economic activity but but even
during a recession there are employers
looking for workers who can't find them
and workers qualified for the jobs
looking for work who can't find
jobs and that's a coordination problem
so in various marketplaces
my colleagues and i have helped develop
labor market clearinghouses that help
people find jobs now here in europe many
people are unemployed in countries like
greece or spain so what methods would
you apply to help these kind of people
in the labor market so so i don't know
enough about european economies to to
give a clear answer but
there are there are long term and there
are short-term problems some of the
long-term problems
require years to repair how how to
find the right education for the
workforce how to
uh how to allow people to move around so
the eu now allows lots of mobility but
of course
uh
in the eu there are barriers to mobility
that don't exist in the united states
where where we speak the same language
across the whole continent so it's not
easy to move from greece to germany in
order to find employment
but
easing barriers to transportation making
making a common currency making
finding common languages that people
work in uh all of these will help
increase labor mobility and and that's
something that that over the longer term
has certainly helped the american
economy to to deal with unemployment
finding partners nowadays is also a
topic for many people how do i find the
correct or the right partner can you
could you help some set as well well so
so there are i mean finding the right
partner is a little like finding the
right job these are matching markets
my colleagues and i have mostly worked
on employment trying to to ease
congestion for instance in the market
for new economists or the market for new
doctors so so most new doctors in the
united states get their first jobs
through a clearinghouse that i've helped
to design
but but increasingly we're seeing
internet dating sites which are matching
markets that have rules and experience
some of the same problems of congestion
for example that that labor markets can
experience
and colleagues of mine have have studied
these and sometimes suggested design
interventions that help them work better
when they work better what does it mean
for example well so
dating markets is a good example
one of the things that people who study
dating markets notice is that women who
have attractive pictures often get many
more emails than they can answer and
this
causes men whose emails aren't being
answered to send more emails so there
starts to be lots of congestion on these
sites not so much information is passing
back and forth between all the messages
one of the things we did in the
economics job market is we allowed job
candidates to send a small number of
signals to jobs they were particularly
interested in that helped employers sort
among the many applications they got to
to understand which ones to interview so
i have some colleagues who made the same
kind of intervention on a dating website
they gave people a limited number of
virtual roses they called them and you
could send a message that had a rose and
a message that had a virtual rose
attached was a little bit of a special
message because you only had very few
roses so those messages got more
attention and made it easier to cut
through the congestion
are there any markets which you would
like to improve or you look at and think
i could apply my theories to these
markets i could improve them well i keep
thinking about
transplantation i'm doing a great deal
of work on that and have been for some
years my colleagues and i have also done
a lot of work on assigning children to
schools in american cities
that's
an important problem
and we're learning how to do it better
and we've we've helped design school
choice
systems in new york city and in boston
and some other big american cities
and we're hoping to learn how to do that
better
certainly you brought up financial
markets
a student of mine named eric buddish has
been thinking a lot lately about how
computerized trading has
changed the need for market rules and
how rules of the market that worked well
when human beings were doing all the
trading may not work as well at the high
speeds at which computers trade so i
think that we're probably going to see
some
changes in the rules of financial
markets how transactions are made that
will help them work better from an
economic stand standpoint are we living
in a stable world or are you worried
about the economy
well those aren't the only possibilities
i think we're not living in a stable
world things are changing all the time
but i'm not terribly worried we
have some crises but uh but by and large
prosperity has been improving over
the last century uh a great deal it's
it's i think few people even if they're
worried about present times would prefer
to live a hundred years ago than today
and so i think the long-term trend is
that we
encounter crises but we we learn to
overcome them we
there's a changing economic environment
but by and large it
helps us live our lives better so i'm
optimistic
and what does it mean for your science
for the economic science does it have to
change
as well absolutely economics is a young
science first of all we don't know very
much
uh
but but you know we're learning about it
and um
some of the things we're learning are
not the things that you often read about
in the newspaper but but more
engineering kinds of things we're
learning how to make things work better
the environment changes the challenges
change and we learn more we're a very
early science it's an exciting thing to
study it's an important thing to study
economics is about what people do
but but there are there are still big
limits to what we understand about that
thank you very much for that interview
you're quite welcome thank you